géopolitique ventes d'armes
renseignements on en parle tout de suite
dans le décryptage
[Musique]
sur ce plateau régis le sommier bonsoir
% arrivant reporter arte france en
direct de paris bastien lachaud député
la france a soumises de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir
bonsoir je commence avec vous abbas et
un à chaud puisque sur le site de la
france insoumise je cite les révélations
de disclose exige des explications
qu'est ce que vous demandez exactement
une enquête parlementaire
nous demandons en effet une enquête
parlementaire nous demandons que toute
la lumière soit faite sur ces sur ces
faits qui s'ils étaient confirmés et
avérés sont une particulière gravité
il met en jeu l'honneur de la france est
en cause les plus hauts responsables du
pays qu'il s'agisse de deux présidents
de la république françois hollande et
emmanuel macron qu'il s'agisse du
ministre de la défense des manuels
macron aujourd'hui ministre des affaires
étrangères le jean yves le drian mais
également la ministre de désarmer
florence parly ces personnes doivent
s'expliquer sur le sur les notes qui qui
ont été rédigées à leur intention et a
priori des notes dont ils n'ont pas tiré
toutes les toutes les justes
conséquences
régis le sommier pas encore de réaction
de la part du quai d'orsay pourquoi
d'après vous le ministère des affaires
étrangères attend le deuxième volet de
cette enquête jeudi soir ou bien tout
simplement paris ne veut pas froisser
l'egypte pour garder de bonnes relations
avec un pays qui vient d'acheter la
semaine dernière 30 rafale alors il ya
des éléments qui laissent penser un peu
oui on m'attend tous de savoir un petit
peu
la deuxième partie et puis le vous
l'avez cité le commet l'en quête de
complément d enquête jeudi soir le fait
que le site disclose a été mon
interrompue sur l'egypte est aussi une
indication que les égyptiens ne voit pas
la chose d'une d'une façon je dirais
très réjouissante
oui la france a des relations
extrêmement particulière avec l'egypte
l'egypte est une dictature l'egypte est
un pays dans lequel on enferme et
opposants mais l'egypte est un
partenaire au niveau des armes très
important vous l'avez souligné
la signature de ce contrat d'armement de
30 rafale qui est deuxième volet la
deuxième place qu'il y avait eu 24 à
falcon était acheté précédent vie a su
au caire précédemment il faut le
rappeler en 2015 il faut rappeler quelle
était l'importance de ce contrat en 2015
il s'agissait du premier contrat signé à
l'époque négocié par le drian avec le
marais chelsea six sous donc le ler de
françois hollande et à cette époque là
c'était le début de la vente de nos
rafale au sel qu'on avait eu énormément
de problèmes allaient aller vendre à
l'étranger et l'egypte avait été une
première à une première victoire
commerciale ensuite il y en a eu
d'autres avec le qatar les émirats
lumbres et il ya tout un tas de pays la
grèce récemment donc si vous voulez les
jt un peu ouvert la voie pour l'afsset
fourniture de matériels dont deux
d'avion aérien et par la suite aussi a
vu d'autres coopérations donc le
problème
le problème c'est le détournement par
l'egypte ce qu indique cette enquête
deux technologies qui sont théoriquement
dédiée à la lutte antiterroriste ce
qu'on veut ce qu'ont fait les français
en justement contractant avec la la drm
donc la direction du renseignement
militaire
un comment un partenaire luxembourgeois
une société la société cae qui a fourni
cet avion de cet avion de surveillance
aérienne c'est que cet avion va il était
censé surveiller des pick up de
terroristes dans le désert or le
problème c'est que dans la zone imparti
à la surveillance en général c'est du
trafic zen proche de la limite voilà ce
qu'on appelle du trafic
comment de bédouins en fait finalement
c'est de l'essence c'est des cigarettes
ça va être des produits de maquillage ça
peut être tout afin de photographier
camp mais ce sont des civils oui mais ce
sont des civils oui exactement hélas la
présence de deux groupes jihadistes dans
cette zone là est assez faible elle a
été plus importante par le passé mais
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas et ce qui
peut expliquer l'embarras aussi de du
quai d'orsay et du ministère de la
défense la sueur ça c'est que cette
opération baptisée siri est
officiellement toujours en cours et
fortement justement bastien la chaux il
ya toujours selon le site disclose dix
militaires français qui seraient sur
place déployant en egypte dans cette
mission syrie qu'est ce que vous
demandez leur rapatriement
égouttez nous demandons déjà des
explications parce que ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit est tout à fait juste
c'est à dire que nos si les faits sont
avérés non moyens militaires ont servi à
des opérations de police qui n'ont rien
à voir avec la lutte contre le
terrorisme et donc qui ont été
totalement détournées de leur objectif
est à partir de ce moment là
cette opération aurait dû être
arrêté cette opération aurait dû être
arrêtée dès la première frappe constaté
des autorités égyptiennes sur des civils
suite à nos transferts d'informations et
de renseignements le
n'importe quel min
cohérent et appliquant réellement c'est
ses fonctions avec honneur remplissant
avec ses fonctions avec honneur aurait
dû démissionner ou auraient dû faire
cesser
ces actes donc ces militaires qui ont
alerté il faut quand même le dire ce
sont les notes qui ont été publiés par
par des gens lisent ce sont des notes de
militaires français qui disent attention
ce que nous faisons conduit à des à des
frappes sur des sur des civils prenez
des décisions les autorités politiques
n'ont pas agi ce sont les autorités
politiques qui aujourd'hui sont en cause
donc évidemment si les faits sont avérés
les militaires français doivent
immédiatement être rapatriés vous voulez
vendre d'armes à l'egypte doivent cesser
il n'est pas possible de fournir des
armes de fournir des équipes pour voir
des équipements mixte duale civile
militaire qui pourrait servir à la
répression de la population égyptienne
par un régime totalitaire qui ne
respectent absolument pas les droits de
l'homme et aujourd'hui nous nous battons
parlementaires français pour la
libération de deux prisonniers
politiques en egypte et dans le même
temps nous avons un exécutif qui
continue de vendre des armes et ses
armes on s'en rend compte aujourd'hui si
les faits sont avérés servent à frapper
des civils servent également avait
traqué via les réseaux téléphoniques via
les réseaux numériques et cela conduit à
des arrestations
de cibler d'opposants politiques si
jamais ces ventes d'armes sont et
l'équipement sont responsables de cela
il faudra que des personnes rendent des
comptes qu'il s'agisse des industriels
qu'il s'agisse des ministres qui ont
autorisé ses ventes
régis donc l'egypte est l'un des
partenaires de la france commercialement
parlant l'a compris au niveau des ventes
d'armes le président égyptien abdel
fattah al-sisi a même reçu la grand
croix de la légion d'honneur des mains
des manuels macron c'était en 2020 c'est
en catimini à l'écart de de la presse
française oui parce que déjà la visite
on s'en souvient en 2020 et posé une
polémique aussi sur ses rapports et
toujours cette situation particulière
que la france et de ses relations
particulières que la france entretient
avec l'egypte il faut dire que dans la
région l'egypte c est quand même un pays
instable que la france a des intérêts il
ya la question de la crise libyenne qui
n'est pas fini aux portes et que
l'égypte évidemment a un poids énorme
dans cette dans le déroulement de ce qui
se passe en libye actuellement notamment
via l'appui qu'elle a calé quelques elle
offre au général haftar donc on est dans
dans de la géopolitique on n'est pas
dans le bus un sentimental le problème
de la france c'est qu'elle veut toujours
jouer sur les deux tableaux quand
j'arrive le drian ready récemment dans
le monde que nos concurrents parlant de
la chine et la russie n'ont aucune aucun
tabou et aucune limite on s'aperçoit que
si ces faits là sont avérés nous non
plus nous n'avons pas non plus beaucoup
de limites quand il s'agit de défendre
nos intérêts mais ça c'est le cas de
tout le monde et après ils font pas
vouloir comment tenir des propos en
jouant les plus vertueux c'est la
réalité et la réalité des relations
alors après ce que ça pose sur la
question des civils c'était je le
rappelle déjà posé sur la question en
mai 2019 lorsque deux des fondateurs
d'ailleurs du site disclose avait été
entendu par la dgse parce que il avait
fait une enquête avait conduit une
enquête justement sur la discorde le
fameux mode à paris qui avait créé des
armes des arbres la destination l'arabie
saoudite pour pour selon le site frappé
notamment à des civils women exactement
vous l'avez résumé mais 7,7 à l'époque
c'était quand même une question
importante ont une influence parle il
était monté au créneau expliquant que
ces armes n'avaient pas été utilisés
mais en réalité en fait il s'avère
qu'elles ont été utilisés dans une
guerre qui il faut le rappeler
aujourd'hui éprouvée prochaine les
estimations de l'onu pour la fin 2021 la
galerie yémen ces 300 morts et donc si
ça veut dire que les armes françaises
ont été utilisés aussi dans ce cadre là
donc à chaque fois c'est un c'est
toujours le problème de la vente d'armes
mais le problème des ventes d'armes donc
vous dira aussi que ces deux cent mille
emplois en francs à la barre c'est
manger dormir et j'en ai la paire sur la
question quelles normes match évidemment
l'acien la shoah par rapport à ça parce
que la france est 3e ou 4e exportateur
de vente d'armes dans le monde justement
vous comprenez cet argument que vient de
de stipuler régis le sommier l'argument
industriel vendre moins d'armes à
l'egypte l'arabie saoudite s'est
également peut-être perdre des emplois
en france
c'est un véritable problème que toute
notre économie de défense soit basée sur
l'exportation d'armes parce que
justement à partir du moment où nous
basons notre économie de défense sur
l'exportation d'armes eh bien nous
sommes prêts à toutes les compromissions
pour vendre des armes la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui nos armées ont des
besoins d'armement qui satisferait
pleinement le carnet de commandes des
industriels parce que les rafales c'est
intéressant de voir ces rafales qui sont
achetés la plupart des rafales qui sont
achetés par des contrats en ce moment
sont 10 rafale d'occasions c'est à dire
que des pays achètent des rafales qui
sont utilisés par l'armée de la
française et l'armée de l'air française
est obligé de racheter des rafale à
dassault pendant et donc au final ça
coûte de l'argent à l'armée française
pendant quelques mois pendant quelques
années nous allons être sous dotées en
rafale voire même on parle de nous
racheter des mirage 2000 pour réside
pour tenir le coup par rapport à ces
rafales qui vont partir à l'export mais
au final on se retrouve avec une armée
française qui était peu c'est c-26
moyens pour pouvoir en vendre donc on
marche sur la tête pour en finir avec ce
système économique où nous sommes
dépendants de l'explosion les armées
françaises besoin équipements
fournissions aux armées françaises des
besoins en équipements je suis sûr que
nous remplissons les carnets de
commandes de nos industriels que nous
n'avons pas besoin de l'export il s'agit
là de renverser le
le renverser le système
économique sur lequel est basé notre
économie défense mais en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est qu'à partir du moment
où nous avons une économie de défense
qui est basée sur l'exportation et bien
en effet nous sommes prêts à toutes les
compromissions pour exporter à tout prix
y compris mettre en difficulté nos
armées en été peut sembler les
équipements dont ils ont dont l oms dont
elles ont besoin il faut aujourd'hui en
finir avec ça il faut évidemment
nationaliser les industries de défense
parce que construire des armes vendre
des armes ce n'est pas une activité
anodine ce n'est pas une activité comme
les autres et nous le voyons aujourd'hui
donc il faut en revenir au système qui
était en place en france dans les années
1980 ou même d'assaut avaient été
nationalisées et dassault notion n'était
pas plus mal portée que qu'aujourd'hui
donc tout ça c'est ce que nous portons
dans l'avenir en commun avec jean luc
mélenchon au niveau de la france
insoumise et c'est aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui serait nécessaire et utile
pour en finir avec ces scandales à
répétition qui met en jeu l'honneur de
la france qui m'attend jeu sa réputation
qui met en jeu sa capacité à agir pour
la niveaux internationaux le mot de la
fin régis le sommier mais le mot de la
fin je pense qu' on le verra dans
complément d'enquêté jeudi parce qu'on a
quand même hâte de voir un petit peu ce
qu'il ya en plus et le l'enquète
complète puisqu'elle est pas encore l ai
pas encore établi les faits bon ce qu'on
a vu c'est effectivement une frappe du
21 septembre 2016 où on voit effets de
l' on atteste ou là les documents
attestent de la présence d'un cessna
armée de l'armée égyptienne dans une
zone est ensuite d'un certain nombre de
pick-up détruits donc ça voilà il ya
effectivement mais y aurait mille
plusieurs dizaines de frappe de même du
même ans donc il faut voir un peu
l'ampleur de cette utilisation des
renseignements sont au programme
rappeler que ce sont pas les français
qui frappe directement des cibles que
l'unc indiquerait l'egypte mais qu'il
s'agit justement de renseignements
apportés par ce programme aéronefs voilà
et que là donc
établir un petit peu l'exactitude de ce
qui s'est passé depuis combien de temps
dure ce programme a priori depuis le 13
février 2016 mais sous françois hollande
et y est il toujours opérant fourni ton
toujours c'est ces informations et s'il
s'avère qu'elles ont dépassé le cadre du
simple finalement de la lutte contre le
terrorisme puisque c'est là dessus
qu'ils emmanuel macron et et comme on le
branche une scission entre eux réaffirmé
leur partenariat récemment et bien il ya
vraiment un problème mais là il faut il
faudra qu'ils étaient au moins
explications et peut-être suspension de
ce genre de pratiques merci régis le
sommier d'avoir répondu à nos questions
vous êtes grand reporter pour arte
france merci également à bastien dachau
d'être intervenue ce soir vous êtes
député elle fit en seine saint denis